un cocktail sans alcool gratuit pour
mettre un peu de piquant dans la soirée
des conducteurs désignés c'est l'essence
du programme code barre qui vient d'être
lancé sur la Rive-Sud le Balthazar qui
avait déjà adopté cette pratique depuis
quelques années à tout de suite accepté
de se joindre à l'initiative on a fait
des motos sans alcool des de la décision
sans alcool on a plusieurs facteurs sans
alcool qu'on offre aux gens qui qui se
porte volontaire pour aider leur ami une
fois arrivé sur place les conducteurs
désignés n'ont qu'à s'identifier on leur
remet un bracelet plus ils peuvent
obtenir des consommations sans alcool
pendant que leurs amis se laissent aller
la seule condition ramener au moins deux
personnes à la maison on aimerait
plusieurs bars nous suivent là-dedans
vraiment essayer d'encourager les plus
une consommation saine c'est pas
nécessairement dans le volume mais
surtout
dans ne pas se mettre en danger dans
l'immédiat pour aller se mettre sa route
quand on est en faculté affaibli le
programme qui a vu le jour à Sherbrooke
il y a 5 ans et aussi en place à
Gatineau et à Laval
la police de Longueuil a fait la tournée
des bars et des restaurants de
l'agglomération pour les convaincre de
participer sur 150 établissements
visités une trentaine ont accepté on
trouvait que c'était un moment propice à
partir le projet le temps des fêtes les
portées de bureau et tout et mais nous
ce n'est pas un projet seulement pour le
temps des fêtes c'est vraiment à l'année
le programme s'adresse à tous les
conducteurs désignés peu importe leur
âge mais aussi de surtout les jeunes
c'est une bonne idée c'est bien ça
encourage d'avoir un chauffeur dans le
fond qui qui consomme pas d'alcool ça
lui permet de consommer quelque chose
pendant la soirée
peu ou taxi ça revient cher c'est 60
pièces des fois le taxi là pour tourner
dans les tranches d'âge de 18 à 25 ans
malheureusement il y a encore beaucoup
d'accidents et encore beaucoup de
conduite avec les capacités affaiblies
et qu'on essaye de faire diminuer ces
statistiques là la police espère que
d'autres établissements entre rond dans
la danse ici Olivier Bachard
Radio-Canada Brossard